أنا مثل أي طفل صغير آخر
بحلم أن تكون قادرًا على أن تكون يومًا ما
لاعب محترف بدأت جدا
صغار جدًا يبلغون من العمر أربع أو خمس سنوات في القاعدة
لقد كانت لعبة كان والدي
متعصب جدا لكرة القدم وأنا أيضا أرى
مستوى منخفض
كان مارادونا دزيكو جيد هو عليه
لقد أتيحت لي الفرصة دائمًا لأكون قادرًا على ذلك
لمقابلته كان شخصًا جدًا
إنه مهم أيضًا في طفولتي
أحد لاعبي والدي المفضلين
أكثر أو أقل من ساعتين من التدريب
النوم اليومي كثيرًا ولكن أيضًا
الاستماع إلى الموسيقى أحب الورك
قفز الراب بشكل عام لكن شبكية العين بفرنسا
هو جيد ولكن قواعد الصلصا باتشاتا وأنا
كأس لافال هو الاستماع إلى الجديد
مصنفة على أنها خارجة عن القانون
إنه روتين يومي لأن
أنا أؤمن كثيرا بالله لذلك أخذت
أكثر من ساعة خاصة بي
قبل المباراة وقبلها بثلاث دقائق
لتبدأ اللعبة
تمريرة كانت خاصة وصحيح أنني
شعرت بأنني بحالة جيدة للغاية ولم أمتلك خطوات
كنت في أفضل حالات الألم
ثم سأقول في الامتحانات
فحص عادي سأقوم به
النادي واكتشاف ورم في بلدي
الكبد
في ذلك الوقت كانت صدمة لكنها جيدة
صدمة سريعة لأن هنا تأتي اللعبة
سأقول أن لدي عقل جيد
أنا مقاتل أجريت مناقشة
واضح ولادة مع الطبيب
سوف يفشل الناس في إخبارهم بذلك
هذا إذا كان لدي شيء خاطئ فيه
في جسدي و د سيكون أفضل
من الأفضل أن تكون قادرًا على إزالة ملفات
بهذه السرعة بين الثلاثاء والخميس
كان القرار بالفعل أزمة و
يوم الخميس كنت قد أجريت العملية بالفعل
صحيح أنه مضى وقت طويل
خاصة للاعب
لا توجد امرأة أخرى
ولكن ليس لديه الكثير من اللاعبين الذين
يمكنه الفوز بدوري البطل و
ناهيك عن من يستطيع رفعها أنا
أعتقد أنه كان خطابًا عامًا لـ
الفريق
النادي الذي عاش عليه اللاعبون
شهرين ونصف الشهر صعبة معي
كنت محظوظًا لأنني تمكنت من الحصول على
شارة الكابتن
بالمناسبة ، لا تزال لحظة عظيمة
بالنسبة لي يبقى امتياز وشرف
وسأشكر دائما
أشكر زملائي على هذا
إيماءة